we've got something really interesting
and a little different for you today so
in the wake of everything that happened
in Charlottesville a few weeks ago while
we were actually on summer vacation
tensions have remained really high
around these debates over whether
Confederate statues in cities around the
South should be removed or whether they
should stay and the statue debate is
sort of centered around statues honoring
Confederate leaders or Confederate
soldiers or states of the Confederacy
and any serious person at this point
realizes that the main point of the
Confederacy's actions in the Civil War
were to preserve slavery right and they
will sometimes say well it was about
states rights but one layer below that
is that it was about means that
maintaining a state's right to have
slaves regardless of what the federal
government said and if you look back at
the economies of many Confederate states
you'll realize that they were totally
dependent on slavery periods so that the
sort of academic debate at the time over
states rights was very low on the list
of priorities compared to the reality
that if they can't have slaves anymore
it is going to impact their economies
and if you look at the timing of when
the Confederate monuments and statues
were put up it was around number one
around 1900 between 1900 1920 when
states were enacting Jim Crow laws to
discriminate against black people and
segregate society and then you had
another wave of it in the 1950s and 60s
as a direct backlash to the civil rights
movement so even if you could argue sort
of academically that the Civil War
wasn't about slavery which you can't
because it was you can then look up what
motivated putting the statues up in the
early 20th century and in the mid 20th
century and you can very quickly see
what this is about
okay so over the weekend there was a neo
Confederate anti-government militia
organization in Tennessee that calls
itself the new Confederate States of
America they traveled to Richmond
Virginia and they held a demonstration
in front of Richmond's statue of
Confederate General Robert E Lee and
there are actually several statues of
Confederate leaders in Richmond Virginia
and these far-right demonstrators came
and
bored of leaving every statue where it
is there were only a few dozen of these
neo Confederate protestors who showed up
most of them were openly armed not
surprisingly but it did provoke a really
big peaceful counter protest by
thousands of people in Richmond who are
in favor of taking the statues down and
what's most hilarious about this
grouping coming to Richmond is how
counterproductive the decision was all
that these neo Confederate protestors
succeeded in doing was sparking a huge
counter protest in support of removing
the statues which outnumbered them by
about a hundred to one they created
awareness for the opposite cause and I'm
showing some of the video of the counter
protests on the screen this has been
gathered by producer Noah Ferguson
working alongside Mike Shea down in
Richmond Virginia
Richmond if you if you're not aware of
the history of Richmond there's a very
long and tumultuous history when it
comes to race relations Richmond was the
capital of the Confederacy during the
Civil War Richmond was the largest slave
trading hub on the East Coast during the
19th century once slaves were kidnapped
in Africa and sent to the east coast of
the US Richmond was usually the first
place they stopped and there they were
confined auctioned off typically to
other slave traders who would then
distribute these slaves throughout the
south of the United States historians
and anthropologists say that most
African Americans today would be able to
trace their ancestry to Richmond
Virginia and because Richmond was the
capital of the Confederacy
there are huge monuments memorializing
Confederate leaders in the heart of the
city including as I mentioned Robert Ely
president of the Confederacy Jefferson
Davis there are high schools in Richmond
named after these people and for years
there's been a lot of debate at both the
state and local level about removing
these statues in Richmond Virginia and
after the events in Charlottesville
Richmond's mayor levar Stoney said that
the Richmond City government should
consider removing the monument so this
militia group shows up in Richmond on
Saturday
counter-protesters show up absolutely no
violence from counter protesters right
we did a long-form piece recently about
the myth of the violent left the left
were not the violent ones in
Charlottesville and they were not
violent in Richmond Virginia either
seven people were detained four of those
were detained for wearing masks in
public which is illegal by statute in
Virginia so I want to get to some of the
interviews with these folks here and
Noah Ferguson and Mike Shea doing a
really really good job on the ground in
Richmond Virginia let's start with some
people who like the statues and say
states rights as a refrain as to why we
had the civil war in the first place
what about the people that wish they had
the freedom to take the statues down
because to them it represents slavery
and oppression why would it right if be
slavery and oppression it's it's not
anything to do with slavery right I mean
history books if you read in the history
books it was state sovereignty mmm-hmm
and then we've also got another example
of people talking about states rights
let's take a look at that one what about
the people that when they come down this
Avenue they say it reminds them of
slavery of being oppressed coop up next
Avenue don't come down this Avenue if
you don't like it go up the other Avenue
right now as I mentioned earlier lots of
people were armed
why were they armed here's one guy
explaining why he's armed I see your arm
today why did you bring a gun Second
Amendment to the Constitution Britt
named by Thomas Jefferson it's
specifically iterates that we have the
right to bear arms to protect ourselves
from enemies both foreign and domestic
who are your domestic enemies that would
be an out-of-control federal government
what about President Trump I believe in
what Trump's doing oh yeah I think he's
good he's a businessman ah this guy
quotes from Thomas Jefferson on the
Second Amendment
he also give this line about well my
domestic enemies are tyranny by the
federal government that's often
attributed to Thomas Jefferson that line
has not been found in any of Thomas
Jefferson's writings period now would
this guy care about that no he wouldn't
and clearly this
guy is the sort of ideologically
committed trumpets that we've talked
about now here's another couple of guys
one who says that counter protesting is
something that people do only when
they're in Kenny garden also this guy
equates Confederate generals to Abraham
Lincoln and defends slavery
take a look I'm here because I would
like two monuments to stay getting out
here and yelling and screaming and
acting like you're in kindergarten or
something others not doing nothing it's
just making people hate you more if you
don't like it or agree with it
look you got Lincoln up there I don't
like him I don't agree with that let's
take that down
I don't like Lincoln because of what he
stood for and what he tried to do and
for his Northern Aggression war that he
put onto the south to take our rights
away slavery has gone on since the Ice
Age No what was the Civil War fought
over it wasn't fought over slavery
that's for sure that's just the best
there's been slavery since the Ice Age
so Lincoln was wrong
also people counter protesting okay Noah
and Mike did try to talk to some of the
auntie foot types but they actually
received death threats for wanting to
film them so here are non auntie feh
counter protesters that Noah and Mike
spoke to actual African Americans
explaining why the presence of these
Confederates Confederacy era monuments
is not good for them take a look at this
what do you have to say to the people
that say hey this represents my heritage
so I'm telling out tell those people
their heritage is based on treason
because those people fought against the
United States that makes them traitors
they are not heroes they didn't do
anything but make causes huge for year
war they killed a lot of people all
right here is another counter protester
talking to Noah and Mike in Richmond
Virginia
well the monuments represent hate you
know they represent a terrible past in
this country and I think they should be
removed and put in a different place
like a museum you know or like some of
the burial grounds cemeteries that's a
better place for them not right in the
middle of our cities all right and so we
need to move them to where they should
be
where they can be looked at in context
now looked at in the 21st century
alright and here's just another couple
of counter-protesters we'll hear from
them as well what do you hope to
accomplish with this March we hope to
awaken some of these white extremists
Alisal war is clearly about slavery
people who say it's not our dissembling
to listen the civil war is over right
these protestors claims about history
are just wrong doing this and saying
these things in Richmond of all places
is sort of the height of absurdity now
on the issue of whether or not slavery
was the central issue of the Civil War
are these people just uninformed is this
an educational issue are they victims of
filter bubbles and echo chambers I've
been talking a lot about that in the
course I'm teaching at Boston College
and ask yourself this why do the four
years of the Confederacy warrant so much
commemoration in contrast to the other
400 years of history in the south right
why does the Confederacy hold such a
special place in the hearts of these
people is it because it was sort of the
last stand for states rights not really
I mean we've had endless Supreme Court
decisions in favor of states rights
since then so why is it it's hard to
make an argument Pat that it's about
anything other than a sort of melancholy
reminiscence about slavery and where
else in the world can you find this
you're talking about a campaign of
people who attack their own country
responsible for over 600,000 deaths all
for a putrid reason as slavery was and
then they get commemorated for it 150
years later it's like a participation
trophy and here is the connection to the
modern politics of 2017 what we're
seeing is people emboldened by Donald
Trump period that's why this is
resurfacing and we need to beat it down
figuratively right I'm not advocating
for violence but it needs to be beaten
down peaceful counter protests are a
tool and I don't agree with those who
say hey ignore white supremacists
because all they wanted his attention
you've got to connect the dots here
right you have to understand how the
rhetoric of the President of the United
States connects to not only the
resurgence II in whites
premise II as we've heard of from from
former neo-nazis and KKK members on the
program but how it connects to policy
proposals right the Muslim country
travel ban the Mexican wall white
supremacist terror in Charlottesville
you can't in any real way deal with that
by ignoring the neo-nazis you you just
can't and you know burying it in terms
of discussion will actually provide
cover to the elements out there and they
exist that want these policies to go
forward so I encourage you do not do it
send me your thoughts on Twitter what
you think about these interviews and we
will continue to having this
conversation because it's a really
important conversation to happen I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership